whose [ __ ] permission are you looking
for go do your thing you're gonna die
[Music]
it's around here um I think it's like
it's like some sort of cafe lets me
check thank you as well
[Applause]
[Music]
put up guys a quick little video on
something that has been dinging my phone
left and right in the DM email and
tweets and I'm just frustrated
aka optimistic that this may be the
video that changes your mindset just a
quick little rant it's called [ __ ]
permission like who the pros permission
are you looking for to do your thing
like who is this person is it is it your
mom is it society is it your partner is
that the people that are commenting in
your social media is it something that
happened to you when you were nine what
permission are you looking for I'm just
so tired you know so many people are
using me right now to give them
permission to do stuff and it is my
literally my literally greatest feeling
of my life the feeling that I through my
content every day on Instagram or my
podcast and giving you permission to win
excites the [ __ ] out of me above my
friends and I can't even like contain it
like very simply like like can you
answer this for me whose permission are
you looking for go do your thing
you're gonna die it's going to end
something bad is gonna happen something
great is gonna happen but most of all
nothing's gonna happen unless you do
something please stop looking for
permission please go do that thing you
wanted to do ask that person out start
that company quit that [ __ ] [ __ ]
you can always get another [ __ ] job
stop asking for permission make the end
of this year at the moment that you
finally make 2018 and you and start
living your [ __ ] life
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hey live from the streets of New York
hey vlog I know today's gonna be a
little bit of a short episode I was even
taking my mic off hence why I'm holding
it but your about this we walk into we
work and I thought you know between the
rants I just did which I'm sure will be
in there some of the b-roll
I'm sure Kyle will chop it up proper
obviously that's a day when most of the
world is traveling this is the Wednesday
before Thanksgiving favorite day because
I love when the world is shut out and
shut down I feel like I'm productive
because you know I hate when everybody's
working when I'm not but I love working
when everybody else isn't anyway
going into we work I thought to extend
the vlogs quality here think what we
were tapped into it's just rethinking
the world you know like why do you have
to work in your home office why do you
have to work and rent a five-year lease
like they took advantage of a retail
arbitrage and a community and a brand
that a lot of people haven't and so as
I'm thinking about voice and I'm
thinking about virtual reality I'm
thinking about you know AR and
cryptocurrency
you know we've lived through the search
era where we're in the midst of the
social content era but for all you 20
year olds please start thinking about
the other trends every industry is about
to be disrupted retail at an all-time
low here in New York as a matter fact
back to we work they just took over the
Lord & Taylor building it hasn't
happened yet but that's where our
headquarters is going Lord & Taylor an
iconic retail that's been here for 100
years point to Old Navy right now I'm
gonna just make a very simple prediction
that Old Navy being there right the
likelihood of that in seven years is
quite low why because more of us are
buying on the internet like why are we
spending six dollars on coffee like like
this young lady just did a fika six
dollar coffee six dollar coffee go tell
your grandfather people pay 6 bucks for
coffee what are the next things
meditation obsessed think it's gonna be
a huge space please use this short
episode and this rant as well to rethink
the game why can an entrepreneur show
your shoes Kyle why can an entrepreneur
sell out of sneakers in 11 hours and
break a website I'm not a rapper I'm not
an athlete oh maybe it's because
entrepreneurship is being put on a
pedestal
maybe nerd culture is taking over
all these things cryptocurrency
self-driving cars slime how to videos
kids that watch we have three year old
searching YouTube with their voice my
friends we are living through the
greatest era of human and consumer trend
shift ever ever was that a Knicks game
the other night I bet you a bunch of you
saw that content
Kyle chopping some of my Knicks video
that people put up on a Twitter you'll
find it
[Applause]
sitting next to a 72 year old man
wearing Easy's
seventy to seventy two-year-old in 2018
is not the same as a 72 year old in 1998
the world has [ __ ] changed go out and
get yours be open meeting people say
hello ask questions understand why
people are wearing backpacks right
understand what this world is doing
right now this is our moment
go in [ __ ] rabbit
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]